It's still going!
Grant:Hey What's up guys welcome back to the Workshop Nate: Today we're gonna be showing you how to make an Easy DIY
Air vortex Cannon
Grant: That's right Nate's The One Who's prototype this project he's gonna Walk You through Step by Step on how you can Make One of These
Air Shooting Bazookas on a Budget Nate: This toy is called an Airzooka and It Shoots Rings of Air over 30 Feet
To make It Work you Just pull back on the handle and release the Handle on the plastic are attached to a bungee Cord Which
Gives It Force When you fire it as the air is Forced out the front of the cannon the air in the Middle is moving
Faster Than The Air on the sides Which Makes It form into a ring The faster moving air in the center of The ring has
Lower pressure and pulls The ring Together to keep it all Together as It travels the purpose of Today's video is to see if we
can Replicate This air vortex gun using easily available and Low-cost materials
The materials you Need for this project are pretty simple and you can find them at Your local hardware store and dollar store i've Got
Some clear plastic tape some Black Duct tape a Nylon screw and nut
Two Wood Screws three Number 12
24 by one-inch machine Screws and Matching machine Nuts a Clear Shower Curtain and a Wooden Stake
So i got this Bucket at the Dollar store if you can Find a Bucket that Doesn't
Have a pour Spout Around the lip iF your bucket has a Handle puller cut it off so It won't get in your Way
We want to cut a circle Out of the bottom of the bucket Leaving a Rim about an inch and a Half Wide
All the Way Around this bucket happens to have an indentation Just The right size?
Now we've Got a hole cut in our bucket Let's make a Handle for It next
Line The Wooden stake Up on the bucket and measure how long you want to support for your handle to be
Once You've Cut the steak to the right size place it back next
To the bucket and Mark three points Near the top middle and bottom
Using a drill bit the same size as your machine screws drill Through the wood and the bucket
Hold The Wooden Stake Against The piece You've already cut and drilled and Measure how long You want it to be as a Handler
Clamping The Handle line The Support rail Up so that Your Handle is approximately in the Middle of the first two Holes that You drilled
Drill Two Pilot Holes Through The Support rail into the Handle
It's a Good idea to sand your Handle down to make It more comfortable to hold on to and Once You've Got that Finished it's
time to find a soda Bottle you can use any size of soda bottle that you have lying Around Because We Really only Need the
Top two Inches using a knife or a Pair of Scissors cut the top off of your soda bar
We're using a blowtorch to heat Up a small nail. if you don't have a Blowtorch
Available You can Also Use a lighter or the flame from your stove
While the Head of the nail is hot melt a small hole near the neck of the bottle
Keep The nail Head back Up and do the same Thing on the other side?
By Melting The hole Rather Than Drilling It you Get Added strength from The melted plastic
Now Let's Mark Two Points on opposite sides of the bucket Almost at the bottom
Heat Up the nail again and melt Holes in the bucket where we've Marked It the same Way we did with the soda bottle
With the bucket and the Handle prepped we can Move on to making a Plastic diaphragm to force air out of the cannon on demand
I'm using a medium weight Shower liner Because it's a Cheap and durable form of plastic That also lets You see through your air bazooka
As you're Shooting at Your target a
Cheap Alternative to the Shower Liner is the Mylar cooler Bags That you can often pick up at the dollar store They aren't
Transparent But They are tough and low-cost
Spreader Sheet of plastic Out on a flat surface so that With the bucket in the Middle you have at least a Foot of Clearance?
On each Side take Your soda bottle and put It about where the Middle of the bucket Was
With a Marker Mark Where your soda bottle is on the sheet of plastic
Remove The cap from your soda bottle top and place The rest of the bottle underneath The sheet of plastic
Lined Up with the circle you Just Marked
Push the cap down over the plastic Until it can Screw into place on the soda bottle Beneath you can see that the soda bottle
Top is now Attached to the plastic
To make It Easier to work with do a Rough cut of the plastic leaving That one-Foot border Around the bucket
With Your bucket Right side Up place the soda top and the plastic on top of the bucket with the cap pointing up
And press the soda top and plastic down into the bucket Until They are about Halfway to the bottom making sure that your soda bottle
Is centered Within Your bucket Mark on the plastic one point where it meets The edge of the bucket measure the distance from where the
Soda Bottle is attached to the lines that you have Marked on the plastic?
Measuring That Same distance Make Additional Marks All The Way Around the plastic in a circle
Connect The dotted Lines to get One continuous circle
If your circle isn't Perfect it Shouldn't be a problem so if your lines Look crooked Here there don't be too concerned about it
The Next step we're gonna do is cover the Whole circle that we've Just Drawn in a Layer of Packaging Tape
To start off Place One piece of tape right across the center of the circle be sure that the piece You tear off is long
Enough That The Edges Reach Just Beyond the circle line Up your next piece of tape with the first four that The edges are Just
Barely Touching
continue adding strips Until Your Whole circle is covered with a single Layer of Tape
The Packaging tape is Very strong and It Doesn't stretch so it's a Good reinforcement for your Sheet of plastic
Once you have a Layer tape covering the Whole circle you want to cut Around the line that you've Drawn?
Now that we Have Attached our tape and cut our circle we're going. To reattach the soda bottle Where it was before
Now we Just Need to make This Handle a bit easier to grab on to
We're going to be using a Nylon nut and bolt. To attach our Handle metal hardware Would Work
Too but these don't weigh as much iF your local hardware store Doesn't Carry
Nylon nuts and Bolts Try checking for Toilet Seat hinge hardware Will also Need a bungee Cord i got These bungee Cords in a pack
of eight at home Depot For about six bucks cut the bungee Cord to remove the plastic Ball
Using a drill bit the same size as your Nylon bolt drill a Hole in your soda cap and plastic You'll want the plastic Ball
From Your bungee Cord to fit over the Nylon bolt if the hole is
Too small use the same drill that They used on the soda cap to Widen it
Thread The Nylon bolt Through The plastic Ball and Then Through The hole in the soda cap
From The Inside of The bottle top Thread the Nylon nut onto the bolt it Doesn't
Have to be threaded down all the Way but enough That it's not going to let go
Alright Guys quick update we Have assembled all the different Pieces That we're going to need for our air vortex cannon But first we're going
to take some Spray paint and decorate it King of Random style
Alright Guys we've Got everything Painted and Ready Let's assemble it into an air vortex Cannon
Once We Have Our Bottle top centered Inside the bucket Let's take a piece of Black Duct tape and Attach The edge of our plastic
Sheet to the edge of the bucket
After We Tape Down the first Edge The second part that We Tape Should Be Directly across from it
Once you Have Your first two sides Attached the next two you want
To do are going to be at a 90 degree angle from those two
In between the four corners That You taped you're going to want. To do a sort of accordion fold
To get the plastic to lay Flat Against the bucket
Go ahead and tape Over any gaps so that The Whole Edge of the plastic is secured to the bucket
All right we've Got our plastic attach That Moves Backward and Forward Now all We Have to do is Attach Our Handle and make it
Spring-Loaded
Drag Your bungee Cord Into one of the Holes in the side of the bucket
Through Both of the Holes in the soda bottle top and then Out through The other bucket hole
Now i want to mark the bungee Cord Where it's leaving the bucket but Because my cord is black i can't draw on it very well
It with a Marker so i'm Just using a small piece of Masking tape to mark it
By Marking The bungee Cord of tape we Know where to tie the knot to keep the bungee cord in the right Place
Stretch Your bungee Cord Out and tie an overhand Knot That Overlaps with Where you Just Marked it with tape
Place the Handle and Support rail Along The bucket where it was when you drill the holes
on the inside of the bucket Attach the three nuts and then use a screw Driver to tighten everything down
Remove The Excess bungee Cord And You're ready to go
Alright Guys There you go your air vortex cannon is Now ready to use
Let'S figure Out some cool things that you can do with your new toy
That was great. One of The Things that i want to try is make it so you can Actually See the vortex of air as It leaves
The gun
Here i've Got a cup of Warm Water and some Dry Ice i'm gonna
Drop The Dry Ice in and try and Suck Up some of the cloud and shoot it Out as a Ring
The Dry Ice Doesn't make a Ring as Well as i was hoping it would the Water vapor That Makes Up the Cloud Warms up
So quickly that It dissipates and you can't really See where the ring Goes
Don't Worry Guys i have an idea for how we can Make a Ring That Will last a lot Longer?
Not long Ago We Showed you how to make some coloured smoke powder and i'm gonna light some off and see if i can Get
a colored Smoke Ring to travel a long distance
Oh That's Great.
Ooh Nailed it!
It's still going it's still visible
There you Go some cool things you can do with your air vortex cannon Shooting Over targets
Launching coloured Rings Up to 30 feet or maybe Just messing with Your Friends family and pets
One of The Things i thought of While i was playing with this is how much fun It might be if we Built a giant
Scaled Up version of This or if we Had a small pocket version look for those in an upcoming video
If you want to buy one That's already assembled for you click the link in the description and you can Get One online
Grant: There you have it Guys The air Blaster cannon Big Thanks to nate for Throwing This project Together for us you like What he's doing?
Give This video a Big Thumbs Up and leave a Nice comment Below
Nate: Thanks for Joining Us for This project Today and we'll see you in the next one talk to you then